well so i want to ask you um you know
before the show you were saying that you
think the republicans are going to win
they're going to they're going to
do you think the republicans are going
to win in 2022 yeah i mean i think all i
think all the fundamentals are there
right like uh joe biden still runs
approvals underwater uh uh
democratic president takes office the
gop usually wins and the fi usually
gains seats in the following election uh
the gop could totally blow it
but i think if they play their cards
right then kevin mccarthy speaker i
think that's likely it's a narrow margin
in the house as is and what do you think
what do you think the first thing
they'll do is oh well i'm not going to
say that i'm not just the first thing
they'll do right no that's why i'm
asking specifically do you think
okay i'll just get into it you said
they're going to impeach bite oh yeah i
want that to happen but do you think
it'll be the first thing they do like
you think they'll be like we're doing it
we're impeaching this guy
uh no it'll be something like
it it'll be a messaging bill right it's
like when when the democrats who took
the house the first thing they did was
pass hr1 the voting rights act which is
part of the broader messaging schema of
republicans hate democracy where the
pro-democracy party vote for us um
i don't know what the what the gop's day
one bill is like you know probably
something on inflation or controlling
inflation or the economy um i do think i
do think that the precedent has been
said that impeachment is a political
tool especially when you are in control
of the house but not the senate so you
know it doesn't matter i think they're
totally gonna beat joe biden because
that's what you're just gonna do now but
do you think they have a good case for
impeaching him or do you think it's
gonna be a lie yeah we'll figure it out
i think they'll figure it out
i think i think it's gonna be ukraine i
think it's gonna be the laptop the
emails the photos of joe biden the the
emails where he's sharing his bank
account with his son and collecting
money and then they're spending money on
each other's behalf there's there's no
specificity in the constitution of what
high crimes and misdemeanors actually
means it's whatever congress says and
it's unreviewable by the supreme court
or any other court it's purely a
political decision so uh they'll find
something because it'll be a great way
to put joe biden on try joe biden on
trial in the in the public eye
and that will line up 2024. do you think
he should be impeached
ah
no
no no really you don't think like all
the stuff he did with ukraine and uh
rosemont seneca and all that stuff
that's now basically confirmed his
hunter biden connected bank account that
they were doing absolutely illicit and
legal things with i don't have i don't
have
strong opinions about uh about the
details there
i do
okay and i think that there's there's a
big argument to make here well i'm sure
i'm sure i'm here for
the house traveling caucus will be happy
to call you in as an expert witness on
the impeachment here no no no no i don't
i don't i don't trust the republicans as
far as i could see them or throw them uh
and i don't i don't think they're even
gonna go going to go with impeachment i
think they're gonna be talk about this
but i don't think they have that much of
a backbone and spine to even do that or
even to match the democrats on many of
their aggressive motions
i think i think the base wants a lot of
things and i think republicans there are
there to placate them pat them on the
back saying yes in just a little bit
just a little bit more just you know
it'll be it will just give you anything
you want to just just vote for us and
then
you they're bad but they're you know i i
think that's the game that they're
playing here that's my own personal
opinion and i might and i might be wrong
the great thing about controlling the
house of representatives is that you're
totally powerless right
as as i was saying as i was saying
before every time the democrats who take
the house they're like oh we're gonna
pass medicare for all we're gonna we're
gonna do it in the house like this is
and if you vote for us you're gonna get
better and then you know they they win
and they go uh maybe not on the medicare
for all things maybe we're not going to
do that because they know it's
politically popular and they can make an
empty promise and the same thing is true
uh
here here's my bet day one bill there's
gonna be a federal there should be
federal law banning crt in school it's
not clear what that means
but they sure are going to ban it and
that's going to be you know they can
prohibit federal funding for local
schools if they get credit for it
then it will move to the senate but then
biden will veto it right well it won't
include the filibuster so it won't
matter right yeah like you you can do
these messaging builds you can do these
and impeachment and p and this goes back
to the point like impeachment is part of
the political process now it's just like
a thing that you do to show that the
other team is bad i'm not even convinced
republicans are gonna win right so i i
we were talking about talking about this
before we started the show you know 538
and a bunch of other outlets say that
historically the opposing party should
win and there's data to suggest it may
happen
but there have been so many rule changes
with like universal mail-in voting which
massively advantages democrats for one
simple reason most of you probably heard
me say it but it's this simple when it
comes to ground activism knocking on
doors democrats can hit a thousand
families in one apartment complex
whereas republicans got to drive
that means that democrats can clear way
more ground during efficacy than
republican ever could that's going to be
massive for them oh that's your ballot
right there fill it out put in your
mailbox you're done republicans knock on
doors they can hit a tenth of the houses
republicans have completely ignored this
those that have been paying attention to
the election have mostly been concerned
about the audits which have been long
drawn out and
some interesting information comes out
that ultimately
no one moves on and nothing happens
meanwhile we can actively see the rules
they're trying to change hr1 like you
mentioned and that like the time
magazine article the shadow campaign to
save the election
they we know exactly what they're doing
to advantage themselves and republicans
don't care
so maybe they should win but maybe they
won't here's the dirty little secret
about most voting uh about most changes
to electoral structure they don't have a
huge impact my favorite example of this
is voter id right like voter id is this
like great racist plot to destroy the
democratic electorate and if if the
republicans get to pass voter id uh then
then it will be the end of democracy as
we know it except that actual studies of
voter id laws that have been implemented
it has no impact on turnout like the the
the results are exactly the same and
this is true avr has an impact automatic
voter registration motor voter has an
impact um i don't nobody knows what
malen is going to do because it's just
like so weird um compared to like status
quo auntie like people voting from home
is just so different after kobed um but
i think in general if you're too lazy to
vote you don't vote if you're not if
you're motivated to vote you like go
stand in the line and accept people
universe and mail in voting universal
mail and voting someone could not knock
on your door and you get up and your
eyes are half closed and they go hi i'm
with such a touch campaign did you vote
yet and they go no like well there's
your ballot right there why don't you
fill it out they're gonna go
i guess or how about the mom walks in
and goes kids did you vote yet and
they're like no mom i don't care just
fill out your vote so we're not getting
ice cream and they go fine whatever what
am i voting for just about democrat okay
they fill it out
it's the ground game i think is most
important because i've i've seen these
organizations i actually did uh i i
volunteered to register registered
people to vote at a concert for death
cab for cutie back in this was like the
obama period
and so guess what every person there was
voting democrat so you've got people
like scott pressler he's registering
republicans he's very effective and boy
do they go after him but the democrats
can easily do voter registration and
when you've got your mailing ballot
sitting right there on your table and
you knock on the door look it may not be
the lazy people who they're gonna get
but there could be negligent people who
go you know i was gonna well might just
fill it out right now okay sure i guess
and then just put in your mailbox
mailman i'll come take it that's gonna
massively increase turnout i mean the
interesting question to me is is
well so a we didn't see a huge increase
in turnout in 2020. so i it could change
in 2022 although like like who votes and
the who votes in the off-cycle election
the interesting question to me is like
the historical norm is that if if
turnout is high democrats win trinidad
slow republicans win for the simple
reason that uh the republican base is
smaller but it's more it's a higher
priority vote it's like old people have
nothing better to do than vote the
republican the democratic base is larger
but they're lower principal vote it's
like young people who are like out
partying and a death cab for cutie
concerts rather than voting um but i
think that that is that is shifting as
the electorate polarizes along educated
lines um we at the manhattan institute
just put out a paper that i think is
really interesting talking about
on-cycling or cycling elections which is
like um so like uh virginia the the big
race is coming up next uh next week
virginia holds its elections off cycle
which is like in 2021 and 20 in
odd-numbered years um and that massively
depresses turnout or like school board
elections are usually held in 18 states
they're mandatorily off cycle local
elections happen in opposite years and
you get these turnouts
larry krasner who's the progressive
prosecutor who just won the democratic
primary in philadelphia he was like this
is like seen as a major victory for the
progressive prosecutor 18 of eligible
democrats voted in the philadelphia d.a
primary uh in i think march uh ten
percent of them voted ten percentage
points voted for krasner eight percent
voted for carlos vega as a krasner one
it's like that's not a referendum um so
you know we're talking about when you
when you answer when you bring elections
on cycle you dramatically change the
electorate i'm interested in
if you boost voter turnout does that now
with the changing
party composition actually start to if
not benefit republicans then
shift the balance in interesting ways i
think i think that's a real possibility
with the republican party capturing
lower education voters the public party
capturing just otherwise disenfranchised
voters if you make it easier for those
people to vote how does that shake
things up i think it's unclear virginia
is going to be a huge sign of things to
come we'll see
neck and neck in virginia yeah but
virginia's gone full blue yeah it's
really funny you know the area we're in
it's a tri-state it's maryland virginia
west virginia and boy do people talk
very poorly about virginia around here
maryland is already bad but these
counties up here are are very red
where we are right now we're in one of
the counties that just found that letter
saying we want to join west virginia you
go over the river to virginia and you're
in loudoun county
you know all about loudoun oh yeah and
then so it's a very conflicted area you
cross the river into west virginia and
it's red i don't know if loudoun is red
or blue but it's it's conflicted and
considering the state itself is is super
majority now or it's not i don't know a
super majority but majority democrat
it's very very interesting to see the
sentiment
of these people in these areas
one of the interesting things about west
virginia is that crt is getting to those
schools as well
it's because these activists are going
and infiltrating rural areas on purpose
i guess it'll be interesting to see how
that plays out in the next few years
when it comes to elections but i think
virginia's election is going to be
i don't know kind of uh um
what's the right word it's about weather
right yeah yeah i mean and and it's it's
really interesting how the two
candidates are playing it right like
mcauliffe is betting on virginia's a
blue state and it's the kind of blue
state that's motivated to turn out
because i hate donald trump right his
agenda is glenn young ken is donald
trump in the flesh he's he's just the
local i'd like you think you know i'm
terrible terry mcauliffe is like a he's
a career politician he's been governor
of virginia before uh he can't keep
straight any of a number of things
including how many people in the state
of covert at any given time um
and but that that's his bet i think
glenn juncken's bet is
he's lighting the policy details he
thinks people are mad about these red
meat issues you think people matter at
crt and that that will get enough
turnout in the non-nova counties to push
it over and you know is it going to
happen for him i don't know i think
you're right that everyone wants it to
be a bellwether i'm not
sure
i think if glenn young can lose his i'm
i still think republicans can take the
house it doesn't cause him to revise
that i think if glenn young can wins
falcons are totally going to retake the
house by a big march it's going to be
interesting it i mean this is a big
election and i think you're right tim i
mean there's a reason barack obama's
getting involved here even making
comments about what happened in loudoun
country county uh which we can't even
talk about here on youtube because of
the adult nature of what happened in
that school
but barack obama said you know it's just
parents overreacting and clearly a court
ruled and saw things a totally different
way the facts speak of a totally
different story and i think that story
that we can't even talk about i think
there's another reason why we can't talk
about i think it might be even
politically motivated is is is shocking
a lot of people in virginia and is
motivating them to vote against the
current establishment against people
like barack obama that are just
conflating it with oh it's just parents
being crazy let's we'll talk about the
member segment because this is a
particularly graphic story and if we
want to get the full details out it's
not something you want your kids to hear
and it's also something that youtube
probably wouldn't be happy with because
it involves a lot of sensitive
uh involves a lot of really disgusting
issues i'll put it that way thanks for
checking out this segment from the tim
cast irl podcast if you want to watch
live you can check out this channel
monday through friday at 8 pm and don't
forget to smash that like button
subscribe to this channel and if you
want more unfiltered and uncensored
content with all of these guests go to
timcast.com and become a member all of
these guests you know and love in
exclusive segments on our website where
we are unrestricted in what we talk
about so you'll definitely not want to
miss it thanks for hanging out we'll see
you all next time
you